the word solidarity appears 16 times in
the treaties the European our European
budget is a living proof a finance and
solidarity euro is an expression of
solidarity and our development policy is
a strong external sign of solidarity and
when it comes to managing the refugee
crisis we have started to see solidarity
I'm convinced much more solidarity is
needed by also know that solidarity must
be voluntary it must come from the heart
it cannot be forced it cannot be imposed
I'm urging the Slovak presidency to
which the divergences and differences
between those who are reluctant to
integrate refugees in their societies
and those who are convinced as I am that
the fair share in relocation and
resettlement is of the essence
I am asking a strong and immediate
action both from greece and european
union to protect what we call in French
lace on forum non la campa non la
compania without protection of this
children European Union is betraying its
historic value in the same spirit the
Commission is proposing today to set up
a European solidarity young people
across european union will be able to
volunteer their help where it is needed
most to respond to crisis situations
like refugee crisis all the recent
earthquakes in italy